bonsoir d'hier soir à quelques heures de
l'extraordinaire opérations du commando
israélien une question se pose est quel
a été pendant la séquestration des
passagers de l'airbus par les
palestiniens
la position exacte du président
ougandais idi amin dada
tous les témoignages des otages venant
de tel aviv et débarquant hier à orry
corrobore amin dada et les terroristes
étaient complices en revanche dès son
arrivée l'équipage d'air france faisait
entendre un autre son de cloche et
rendait hommage au président ougandais
pour son souci d'assurer leur sécurité
leur confort
sur le plan diplomatique internationale
la même dualité se retrouve si dans le
camp occidental
la satisfaction est quasi générale la
france toutefois n'a fait aucun
commentaire officiel l'union soviétique
et les pays africains condamnent
l'opération israélienne en outre et
c'est à souligner le secrétaire général
de l'onu monsieur cours de valdaï s'est
élevé devant l'organisation de l'unité
africaine l'ua contre ce qu'il a appelé
une incursion israélienne en ouganda la
fin de la tante la fin de l' angoisse et
14 français qui se trouvait parmi les
derniers otages des palestiniens avec
eux les dix membres de l'équipage de
l'airbus d'air france ont été longuement
acclamé les embrassades des
retrouvailles les larmes de joie mêlée à
des vivats pour israël des hourras pour
l'équipage l'émotion de parts en
retrouvant leurs enfants et puis les
déclarations peut être partisane
certainement passionnés d'hommes du
boeuf
ayant vécu une détention qu'ils
reprochent en commun aux palestiniens et
aux ou landes les forces ougandaises
était manifestement de connivence avec
les commandos de façon tout à fait
évidente avec embrassades entre les
commandos et les forces ougandaises avec
également échange d'armes entre les
commandos et les forces ougandaises et à
l'arrivée avec des chaudes félicitations
des ougandais au commando c'était
absolument évident pourtant dès leur
arrivée les membres de l'équipage d'air
france - sensible sans doute à la joie
des israéliens disait un communiqué dans
lequel il souligne l aide apportée par
le président amin dada sur l'aéroport
d'antenne et mais nous avons toujours
été gardés par le commando qui avait
reçu quelques renforts de palestine et
nous avons toujours eu à faire ces
hommes là ce sont toujours eux qui nous
ont gardés vous dit l'attitude des
autorités ougandaises a été de nous
fournir la nourriture
la sete
ce confort e petit confort matériel des
100 ans qu'on puisse dormir
il y avait quand même des enfants de
femmes vous avez eu des contacts avec le
président mindana président à une
attaque du noir lui même et nous disait
qu'il était en contact avec différents
pays sans les nommer et qui fait
déployer ses efforts pour résoudre la
question le
qui ont pas dans le secret des dieux
comment dans combien de temps s'est fait
opérer le raid israélien communique plus
quinzaine de munich